you're a huge Star Wars fan the massive
Star Wars man and you're obsessed you've
been obsessed with like being in a Star
Wars movie even if you're in a wookie
costume you said I'll definitely play a
wookie right yes I would do that so well
you would yeah or whatever you just did
it like you believed be very good wookie
do you remember seeing Star and you
haven't first of all I ever been in one
no and the truth is it at first it's
okay because there weren't very many of
them right but now there's a lot of them
and I still have a better one what do
you know that more than they make the
more insulting it is that way star wars
109 and it's it's not like it's a secret
that you want to do it yeah national TV
over and over again yeah I will audition
I'll play wookies I'll play Jedi's I'll
play bad guys I mean I was so the last
time I'm Dustin was so good I loved the
Han Solo when I just look and you see it
in there and there's Woody Harrelson
he's in plain of the Apes he's in the
storms he's got like every job so wait
your your attitude is if Woody Harrelson
can do it I can do it Woody Harrelson is
one of my favorite actors of all time
bar none okay but I'm saying we're the
same kind of age like can I get an
audition show turn into an audition tape
that's what this show is right yes you
know I'm just talking about my life
yeah yeah on you what it's like I think
to myself when I go see on so I came too
old to play ha now I'm gonna enjoy
watching this movie Oh Hans got a buddy
Woody Harrelson and it's I don't get to
go on I mean nobody thinks that I think
the words out that you said no to
Independence Day I think the word is out
I got a deserve forgiveness
you